okay here we
[Music]
go so you were saying we have it's um
it's Native American History
Month
yeah yes it's native what it's American
um Indian Heritage Month I'm sorry
American Indian Heritage Month yeah
American Indian Heritage Month but then
I was seeing another Trend just a start
of a month
of is it is it gay week
no that was that was last month it was
uh lgbtq awareness month this one is uh
oh it's transgend transgender Awareness
Month yes yeah this one it was lgbtq
appreciation month so it's okay hold on
a second I want to make sure so it's
American Indian Heritage Month yes which
I'm just I don't even know we were still
are we still saying Indian is it Indian
American Indian and then transgender
awareness month month yes yeah uh okay
well so I just want to make sure I get
this right folks because we make all the
references available ailable uh but in
honor of your guest is as good as mine
uh seems appropriate let's let's run
let's run uh smells like two spirit
[Music]
yeah
myir is myin
is
at4 I'm
un
[Music]
my
slow SL
[Music]
not dangerous here
now us we want
control
[Music]
CCH my
culture
yeah
[Music]
hey can we
all this to rest your love makes me feel
the best you one person you business
my
Wii word
[Music]
is
Hell ter
now we want control that sh me right now
you're
my of my racial and
transgender
and
[Music]
yeah trigger
one when are dangerous here is one now
that a p
we want
control cry now that
a
homophobia
patriarch great
culture I'm
AED I'm
offed I'm
offended I'm
offended I'm I'm
offended remember none of this is
possible without you join the fight and
sign up for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub
[Music]
today
Str that's what I
[Music]
know
all right okay I got that out of the way
um Gerald is uh he's in Florida he's in
Mar Lago right now so we have a little
bit of a different little bit of a
different Roundup uh by the way was yeah
hope hope uh hope Pelosi's been using
Roundup for a
while that's how Nick depalo starts a
show how many of you uh how many of you
hope Nancy pel's been using Roundup in
her garden for the last 40 years roaring
Applause no sometimes he walks half the
room so uh we have a lot to get to today
Elon Musk was on Joe Rogan in the
Halloween special to talk about why he
bought X and what he saw there so that's
pretty important uh some new updates on
uh former Vice President Joe Biden's
82,000 emails H involves hunter in
Ukraine and then uh we're going to get
into a couple of new stories did the IDF
really bomb a refugee camp uh because
Israel now has started a a land invasion
of Gaza which is why we'll actually have
a military expert on the show uh John
Spencer later on uh where uh actually
replacing Gerald today uh Josh firin
he's not in third chair we're going to
have a segment Josh knows War where
you'll be conducting the interview Josh
Yes sounds fun and you're going to be in
a Bricktown Bricktown comedy club in
Oklahoma City yes this Sunday I'm at
Bricktown Comedy Club November 5th
November 5th sorry I didn't have I
forgot the date I'm not good with date
so here look before I move my question
to you is there's a lot of
misinformation and it's not lost on me
on both sides regarding Israel and
Palestine now it doesn't change the fact
that I want every single last member of
Hamas um to die horrible death okay but
I also understand that there are both
sides here kind of reporting some some
uh updates or death counts that are
really at the very least hard to verify
so genuine question to you are there any
Publications sources Outlets that you
still trust to deliver accurate news
comment below I get it it's hard in the
age of this is the information War age I
mean Alex Jones was right about a lot
and uh we're going to dive right into it
but in third chair you hear this you
know him you love
him I descended from his loin that is
pops Crowder how are you sir I'm great
that's such a great Groove though if we
could just play that every once in a
while well it's a song about
impregnating women in clubs so I don't
know if you I don't know if he knows the
lyrics I don't know the words uh and
before any of that it's a Josh we were
talking about this transgender Awareness
Month don't is it just me don't you feel
like that we've already had one yeah and
also like uh we're aware yes exactly
like I'm not like we can all tell I
don't think we've ever been more aware
of anything like kids in the' 60s
weren't more aware to not play with
blasting caps
everybody trans visibility Harry Potter
CL they want to be seen we see you yeah
we see more than we'd like to yeah
exactly somebody could do some research
but I think June is their month that's
Pride that's Pride that's a different
thing yeah trans visibility month where
now it's like it's the rules are
reversed that's the macro now this is
the we all have to show our gratitude
yeah no you got to thank them for their
transness you got to yeah thank them for
their courage yes thank you for wearing
that dress with those
shoes I know I took a risk now I know
exactly how they feel on the West
Bank I have to shave every day yes
speaking of West Bank your your your
your left is kind of banking it's
banking left a little bit with the fake
well Joe Lewis didn't really appreciate
gay Williams costume yesterday oh no he
didn't he did not see he did not want to
see him he took a wide swath around no
exactly very odd it is man which by the
way it's I mean that's that's a great
litmus test because um he's color
blind all he saw was the weird gay crap
he's just got a good judge of character
yeah he a good judge of character how
many months it's what we have four
months now how how many months for the
wound to heal okay this is just I think
it's a four-month recovery four month my
preferred friction
[Laughter]
month hey you saw the ride you bought a
ticket anyway you know what just let
people if you're watching on YouTube you
should be watching on Rumble so at some
point today if you haven't already
you're going to see
this just head on over to rumble okay
what the hell's the difference I just I
just got hit with this tool man told me
he like oh no we got to go American
Indian Heritage wants and transgender
whatever okay also that's it's a shame
that the they're you know minimizing the
Native American month or Indian American
remember exactly what it's called you
know somebody's capitalizes oh yeah oh
yeah there's one native trans person
that's just
like hey I'm called
one who split snatch
hi hey do you think do you think all the
trans people are participating in No
Shave
November I hope so Native Americans
certainly are cuz they're a hairless
people yeah designed perfectly by God
that's
[Music]
why they call me big little
gash my native name they call me squats
with
[Music]
every
yeah big head smaller well not smaller
body but you and your Fred Durst hat put
it backwards oh he looks the same now
only just completely white just white he
looks like Santa
D
good what do you want for Christmas I
want the
nookie Santa's going to come down your
Cher he's going to be rolling rolling
roll all right it's just one of those
days oh why do you have that on the
soundboard this
look oh my gosh it's like it's like uh
someone tried to kill Chucky with bleach
I had hits in the early 2000 so good I'm
going to kill your sister all
right and Britney Spears is dead so uh
here's a here's a Muslim woman before I
move on and we have I'm sure Mr Spencer
will love this as his introduction uh
John Spencer and I'm looking forward to
you actually doing the interview with
him you know because you both by the way
thank you for your service John yeah I'm
going to learn a lot from him pops Crow
you didn't thank him for his service oh
thankk you for service yeah there you go
thank you all
right you get one free miss a thank you
for your service okay that's what we
call the grace Miss thank you for your
service so here's a Muslim woman in a
hijab um showing Tik Tok how to live
your uh best life without showing your
your face this is why I didn't see my
wife's face before marriage go when my
dad approved of our marriage he actually
told my husband that he could see my
face once before marriage so why did you
reject it the reason is I knew you from
working together for several years
because he's gay doesn't want to see
your face with you want to be with you
regardless of how you look not only did
I do that but I also got married to you
without seeing your face Muslim women
cannot go to the gym in a face
[Music]
fail Imagine That Smell us it's a
struggle for me to eat outside anywhere
and sometimes like I can always just
pull up my veil like this eat through
here but I actually found a better
solution we actually have a t there is a
window so I can just put it down when
I'm eating have my bagel turn around and
C my and eat this way everything's
covered that's a Jewish it's women are
supposed to cover certain parts of their
bodies even in front of other women I'm
supposed to cover from chest to knee in
front of other women but I prefer to be
a little bit more modest so while
swimming in an all female pool I would
wear long swimpants with swim shirt on
top that would mean my veil would come
off my hijab would come up but my swim
cap would stay on what if the Lifeguard
is a man then I won't go swimming when
she's when she's adding the layers it's
like the Weezer Pork and Beans
video every shirt you can imagine that's
a great pool what's most offensive is
the horrible form first off you do some
compound
movements also they look pretty light
those weights are light yeah I know and
but right like why did I make my wife
wear a veil oh one guess she
ugly yeah wear this Veil put on this
fake
mustache fake and people will protect
it's their right it's their choice you
know this is the this is the intersect
right intersectionalism it's just
whoever they view as most oppressed most
oppressed so they support Islam right if
they're in we're talking about Israel
and Palestine but in general Islam
versus Christianity but then they have a
pride flag where of course the Muslims
don't allow for any pride flag you think
they have trans awareness month but the
issue is it's just hey they're oppressed
that's the worldview of the left is
whoever is most successful must be bad
rich bad if you're a majority okay
you're white bad if you're straight bad
and so this is how they end up
supporting ladies who by the way this is
not their choice by law in Islamic
countries they don't have a choice maybe
in the United States but women
drown when you look all throughout all
throughout of the Arab world the the
middle they will drown wearing it's like
they're getting waterboarded and I love
how the make it seem like it's really
convenient it's like eco-friendly stuff
it's really convenient you don't have to
flush your toilet just use some old oak
Ash and pop Perri and have a dry toilet
it's like okay what I can't sometimes I
can't eat in public bring this tent
everywhere I go yes exactly I just need
the tent from
Congo this is my snack
tent it's the same people that will
support this cuz they're the most
oppressed the same people that if you if
they saw a Conservative Christian white
man talking to his wife a certain way
they'll go wow what a piece of crap yeah
exactly and you're like okay like yeah
what do you want your wife to wear
Prairie dresses well you just supported
that woman who was in a ninja outfit
shut up and she's loving it though she's
just she's just loving the status of the
victim card and and none of it is to
honor god notice that that didn't come
out once it was all this is what I this
is my ritual this is what I do this is
my prescription to honor my father yeah
yeah yeah this is how I I go in a tent
arranged marriage do you bring a tent
everywhere right yeah she just has it on
her back like she's just a hiker yeah
and you know underneath that scarf it
just there's just a blower there you can
see it was hanging
on that's why you didn't want to see the
face he's like I've seen enough already
protrusion he's married Daniel Stern all
right don't shoot me in profile don't
ever shoot me in
profile ah it was the sound of an air
strike flying in the Gaza all right
let's move on to Elon Musk uh was on
with Joe Rogan yesterday uh and this is
always you know it's always interesting
to see Elon Musk um some people say I
think he's disingenuous because he's
come to this later in life I don't I
think you're watching a man develop uh
in his later years sort of becoming
aware and certainly I bet you as he's
gone into the Twitter files same thing
with honestly uh uh president Donald
Trump some people say former president
some people say sitting president I say
sitting president okay I think that he
was somewhat fiscally conservative and
then all of his leftist friends turned
on him and then he real realized that
these people weren't his friends and you
saw him become more right-wing more
conservative you comment below uh
because I see a lot of criticism toward
Elon Musk but I think that he has some
people in charge of Twitter sometimes
who aren't necessarily following out his
prescriptions as seen by many people
here in at the ladder with Crowder uh
crew who uh have been suspended
repeatedly yeah well Yakuza you know you
may have committed crimes so uh and you
can follow I did read those yes yes I
had to wash my eyes out yes yeah well
well the good thing is you know you
won't have to take part in trans
visibility day he was right though yeah
but then tomorrow's trans auditory month
so I don't know what that is auditory
month going around checking them yeah
just the weird noises yeah it's just
it's just an it's just a noise
perpetually of father is going
GH all month okay so yesterday Elon Musk
he was on The Joe Rogan show and uh he
talked about quite a bit let's just
let's set this up with the first clip
what was it ultimately that led you to
make the decision to do it I mean this
is going to sound uh somewhat
melodramatic but I was worried about
that that it was having a corrosive
effect on
civilization uh that it was uh just
having a bad a bad
impact okay and you know what that would
make sense because a lot of the time
people every person says right well I
want to make a difference that's why do
what I do well you could do that you
don't have to run a multi-billion dollar
Enterprise you know I've always said
with this this is a business that we run
uh unlike a lot of conservative media
entities it's not a nonprofit and by the
way we're funed by viewers like you do
consider joining mug Club at L with
cr.com mug Club it's what allows us to
do this we have full half of the show uh
Alex Jones of course who everyone else
ran like their hair was on fire and we
we say nope you know what hey we want
them on our team Brian Ken you have uh
you have Josh here all the time we have
the Hodge twins we have Friday show Nick
depalo every single day yeah guns and
gear um so I get it this is a business
but it's not just just business however
if you have you look at Elon Musk he did
risk something he didn't need to buy
Twitter if anything it might have harmed
him financially right there was a risk
there this was not a guy who needed to
purchase it he bought it LO when it was
losing money yes exactly yeah and as far
as we know it may still be losing money
so um he talked about too how the left
was using Twitter to spread his message
so the point is I believe what he's
saying there because I look at what he
risked when people say I'm trying to
help the I want to do better for the
world and all they do is line their like
a perfect example Al Gore Al Gore
sitting on the board at Apple he only
makes money off of that if you know if
climate change is not the existential
threat that you believe it to be Al Gore
is out of a job sort of like if racism
were to go away which it largely has in
the Western World Al Sharpton is out of
a job Also if anyone requires someone
who's literate with prompter Al
Sharpton's out of a
job he's not good yeah he's not good
he's got he's got a word problem so uh
Elon mus got into his vision kind of for
the platform right and that he discussed
that there was a government collusion
under Twitter which he suspected but now
I keep getting confused Twitter X if I
say Twitter or X just guys you can
comment below you can admonish me
yourself because I'm probably going to
go back and forth here um he also talked
about how and having spent time of
course in in California I thought this
was pretty Illuminating how Twitter was
exporting San Francisco's mind virus to
the world if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the X
FKA Twitter headquarters it's a zombie
apocalypse now you have to say well what
philosophy led to that outcome and that
philosophy was being piped to Earth you
know a philosophy that would be
ordinarily quite Niche and
geographically constrained so that that
sort of the
fallout area would be limited um was
effectively given an
information a
weapon um a tech Information Technology
weapon to propagate uh uh what is
essentially a mind virus to the rest of
both um and the outcome of that mind
virus is very clear if you walk around
the streets of downtown San Francisco it
is the end of civilization and and this
is important because you'll hear a lot
of people say well you know you have
Fringe liberals right you have them on
both s okay all right let's let's let's
go with that let's say that the view
that children you know at drag shows is
fringe even though everyone in the DNC
supports it let's say that puberty
blockers uh for children let's say that
like a 90% marginal tax rate um let's
say that all of these ideas would be
considered Fringe or exe or abortion up
until including birth okay but if those
Fringe Liberals are in charge of 90
plus% of the information on planet Earth
is it still
Fringe so let's go to Overlay G1 here
Matt I'm going to go in a little bit of
a different uh order if you look at San
Francisco Silicon Valley we're sort of
using it interchangeably they host the
big Tech headquarters for Twitter or X
Google which means YouTube Apple
Facebook meta which means Instagram
that's all in effectively one small
region of Earth and then you look at the
employees including the higher up
Executives they donated entirely
entirely to Democrats in 2022
99.73%
to. 27% by the way there's a rounding
error of plus or minus
27% I was going to say that one person
got fired for sure right what it's just
like think about Nazi propaganda was
everyone in uh in Germany a Nazi of
course not no but the propaganda leaving
the country guess who was in charge of
the information of the messaging do I
think that it's a mainstream view of
America that there should be drag shows
on Main Street and at the Children's
Public Library no but it is it it is a
diard view it is a fundamental tenet of
the leftist worldview which is held with
with almost hallowed regard from people
at Big Tech and of course those in the
DNC who work with them and I think
that's why this interview was so
important he's talking with a guy Joe
Hogan who was admonished by Jen Zaki and
I also believe Karen John pieron we
really hope that spotifly does more to
uh to uh to uh make sure that Joe Rogan
is not spreading misinformation think
about that insane from The Office of the
President of the United States yes that
comes the official representative who's
their role is to speak in the white
house that's the crazy you're right
you're talking about a guy who came
about these views later in life speaking
to a guy who's coming to the right later
in life mhm you know guys like Tim P
Russell bran these people it's happening
all over the place yeah people are
starting to think like adults yeah
people of influence yeah no Trump's sway
with the black community there's a lot
of there's a lot of change happening
that's such a that's such that's such a
generational thing that way they
complimented by insulting them yeah I
think it's so sweet that you're now
acting like a
grownup well you know the CL classic
Dennis Miller line if you're you've
reached a certain age and you haven't
thought about such things then you've
lived an asshole's life yes well and you
know I'm glad these guys have come
around they're sitting there across from
one another yeah we don't have to agree
on everything but I think uh free speech
is a big one and certainly people who
can be in positions of control uh and
this is also by the way why I I want to
go back remind me to go back to the idea
of nonprofits and 501 c3s because I know
we have Mr Spencer on so we might have
to to clip this along so Elon also uh
went on to say that under Jack dorsy uh
Twitter which is now X was functioning
effectively as a state public like Jack
didn't really know know this but the
degree to which Twitter was simply um an
arm of the government was not well
understood by the public and uh it was
there was no it was whatever the
official government I it was like prda
basically um you know it's a state
publication is the way to think of old
Twitter it's a state publication it's
good that was one of the things about
the old Twitter was the
propaganda and yeah the adherence to
whatever the CDC was saying and the
dismissing of legitimate scientists now
people will say and this is why just so
you know and Joe Rogan is is the biggest
show on Earth so this is not at all uh
to uh diminish what he does but this is
why with this program we make all the
references publicly available because
these two people are having a
conversation an organic conversation and
that's great that's important we also
want to make sure that you are prepared
when the media tries to fact check and
say that's not true that you have the
references of bibliography right in
front of you that's why we put the link
in the description and you can see all
of the references at ler.com because
they just discussed those now I'm going
to tell you that's correct the media is
going to try and say once it picks up
steam that it's not that's why we make
the references available just a
different approach uh the Twitter files
verified by the way that the FBI
colluded with Twitter to suppress
stories specifically at the Biden
administration's request most notable
the hunter Biden laptop story so when
that came out we're going why was this
throttled on Twitter Jack dorsy gave an
explanation well it could be
misinformation and of course they never
reinstated it which affected the entire
outcome of the election by the way if
that story was allowed on social
everywhere meta Twitter Facebook right
Instagram all those places that was
allowed to proliferate just organically
as any other Story the election is
different regardless of changing the
election laws regardless of mass mail
and voting Joe Biden doesn't win a
single swing state think about that the
hunter Biden laptop story that didn't
come from just Twitter thinking it was
misinformation who determines what is
misinformation in this case it was the
FBI El also goes on to uh uh make the
claim we will see if this is verified
here spoiler alert it is that's
foreshadowing spoiler alert it's a dude
trans we're aware yes we're aware we see
you we are so aware
seen uh he also uh makes a claim that
this was the result of liberals
suppressing uh anything to the right of
their beliefs also in collusion with
government
basically oppression of
um any any views that would even I would
say be considered middle of the road um
but certainly anything on the the right
I'm not talking about like like far
right I'm just talking mildly right the
people like Republicans were suppressed
at 10 times the rate of Democrats um now
that's because uh old Twitter was
fundamentally controlled by the farle
everything is to the right if you're
farle everything is to the right now
here's the thing I wouldn't say farle
there the one correction I would make
mainstream left mainstream left is farle
and just to be clear when people try to
say oh they've gone far right and gone
far left no the right has gone slightly
left and the left is far left so if
you're looking at the Overton window
where it shifted okay here
Republicans I guess I should it's my
right your left so maybe I should do it
okay here Republicans I have to do it in
reverse here we're Democrats
conservatives liberals we're using the
American um kind of nomenclature here
all right it didn't do this this it did
this let me give you some examples cuz
that's a big myth that a lot of people
used to fence it and say I'm talking
about the far-left
okay we talk about uh no cash bail okay
that's a big one tolerance of crime in
big cities okay you talk about not just
you know at this point not just talking
about weed black tar heroin being legal
you know like in your home state uh
ideology which includes hormone therapy
and gender surgeries for kids right
cities and states becoming safe havens
for uh trans minors and by the way
teachers Hiding Children from their
parents if they want to
go into uh hor well if they want to
undergo trans if they want to undergo
sex reassignment surgery let's call it
what it is or if they want to go to a
hormone a puberty blocking Clinic I
don't know if it's called puberty
blocking Clinic you get the point the
point here is look at all of those
policies now name me one one just one
comment below National member of the DNC
who isn't on board with that
you want to say oh oh everyone has gone
uh extreme we're talking about as
recently as
2010 Barack Obama ran on an anti-gay
marriage
platform the only president to enter
into office who was PR gay marriage was
Donald
Trump historically historically yeah
think about that now I don't believe
Barack Obama any further than I can
throw him which by the way is pretty
far you're pretty you're pretty strong
he's bird bone he's pretty light yeah
now Michelle I need a wind out I might
need an
adle grab her by her dick
around s
Hammer by the way Elon sounds very high
no I was going to say I was going to say
tired yeah he does tired and just like
when he's talking about the end of
civilization in in Cena you know
precursor in in San Francisco just seems
like he's so distraught yeah it does
what's behind the grin is it seems like
there's more he knows something that he
he's not quite sharing yeah and there's
a deeper issue he leaves Trails of
breadcrumbs if you see things that he
retweets for example things like you
know cabals of pedophiles now that
doesn't mean that we're talking about
some Satan worshiping Spirit what he's
talking about is people in people in
positions of power who have a vested
interest for example in allowing uh open
borders because of sex trafficking in
which they partake things like that
things that have been verifiably proven
to a small degree in individual cases I
mean Epstein I think is I mean I think
it's
relevant I think it's relevant that the
most powerful people in the world were
visiting sex Island 26 times 26 times
that's just Bill Clinton that's two
dozen that's two Baker's
Dozen yes the math is yeah it seems I
was doing the math I haven't been to
Chick-fil-A
2016 un believable but they move you
through faster they have a very
efficient driveth through system good
drive very good drive
system but think about it so now you
have we had Barack Obama who was now I
believe that marriage is between a man
and a
woman that's why I'm married clearly to
what is a
woman she's a woman come on no no
no don't get all we weed up I'm married
to a real life
lady
fine lady and not is I'm not right
Michelle Michael I'm a fine lady you
heard
it so we went from anti-gay marriage
Barack Obama to puberty blockers for
children and then really you've been
with us the last two years sex
reassignment surgery for children and
hiding the children from the parents if
they don't want their children to
undergo sex reassignment surgery oh and
by the way parental rights are just a
it's a byproduct it's a con construct of
white supremacy so is the nuclear family
we have not gone far right and far
left we have all gone left and the left
has gone incredibly far left which makes
them now the mainstream left I'm not
going to use the term the far-left
because I don't know it would be
considered far-left hold on a second Joe
Biden supports gender reassignment for
children so does saki so does Karen jier
so does Camala Harris so does Gavin
Newsome so if on we can't say that's far
left right these are these are the most
prominent National figures what would be
far left for crying out loud marks
wouldn't be further to the left of them
socially and as a general rule of thumb
anything
leftist throughout history it's about as
useful as mistake we've made we were not
above Chad who's you know Charles
Xavier's brother we we've hired him we
have him on retainer leftism is about as
useful as Chad our resident
X-Men come
on I can't
turn
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that's why he had the that's why he
had the Wiggles in the office today not
getting a lot of exercise Joe L isn't
doing him any favors he not no he's kind
of a dick I like
it you can give him a tug into a you're
the one who dove into an empty
cool um so musk also uh went on to say
and this is kind of the macro picture
that uh under his ownership um X he laid
out a vision which is good you have
people who just complain and don't letay
out a vision for the way things should
be and and I don't necessarily know that
this is detailed but I think it's a good
start he said X Twitter should represent
the collective consciousness of
humanity that is that X FK Twitter um
should uh represent the sort of
collective consciousness of humanity so
now that that means that they're going
to be views on there that you don't like
um or disagree with
um but that's Humanity but the Taliban
is on
Twitter
right a valid question valid it is funny
coming with that wig on it's just a
little fun who was he was he was was he
Ric Flair what was it's hard to tell cuz
he's playing he has a Puerto Rico
baseball jersey on which I don't know
who I don't get oh no gay Williams it's
too obscure a reference it's too obsc
yeah it's probably a a pun or something
I'm sure I'm probably missing something
hey so he talks about Humanity you know
who doesn't care Willi pissed off Puerto
Rican you know who doesn't care about
humanity and he commented on this too a
little bit like the tortoise in the race
he does seem tired but he commented on
who doesn't care about Humanity Elon
Musk specified George Soros Soros I
don't know I mean he had a very
difficult
upbringing um and uh I in my opinion he
fundamentally hates Humanity that's my
opinion really yeah I mean well he's
doing things that ero the fabric of
civilization yeah now can we confirm
that's why we make all the references
available Soros spent about $40 million
on uh leftist da campaigns All Over
America right to be soft on crime uh to
be clear Soros da in this country they
represent about one in five
in America but they preside over 40% of
the nation's
murders and he also funded nearly just
$15 million to Pro Hamas protests this
is a guy of course who's a eugenicist
who does believe that overpopulation is
a problem he's funded all kinds of
studies and funded movements to try and
reduce population of Earth this is a guy
who also most notably pointed out where
the Jews were hiding you know to the
Germans during the Holocaust uh this is
not a good guy but he is a
yes he is yes he has a a face that only
a mother could hate oh uh speaking of a
face uh so Rogan was going as his
doppelganger oh that makes sense that's
right oh oh for that guy it's very meta
it's very meta all right so my question
to you is look let me ask you this see
seeing where he lines up do you think
that Twitter has improved under musk's
watch and uh how far of a way do you
think that it has to go how confident
are you with him at the tiller of the
ship I think that this shows uh this
does show this was more than just I'm a
conservative you know delivering a red
meat line to a camera for a few clicks
on Instagram this was a guy I do think
who was really kind of bearing his soul
and I think a development it doesn't
mean that Twitter's I think that
pragmatically Twitter is a little bit
rougher in some ways I don't think he's
really fixed the Bots I think the
trending issues probably have a long way
to go but the heart of it of wanting
free spech to exist there is a move in
the right direction there only two
places really doing that right now
that's Rumble and uh and hopefully twist
Twitter but Rumble has been a lot more
consistent with that uh which is of
course why mug Club is Rumble mug Rumble
is mug Club you can join mug Club we've
already talked about that but um we're
really happy to be in a partnership with
them and uh you I do think the Twitter
has has improved quite a bit you weren't
active on Twitter before J I wasn't I uh
I hated Twitter I just I couldn't first
of all I wasn't good at it yeah I still
am not good at it uh as a comedian I'm
supposed to making jokes and all I do is
share videos of stuff I'm angry about or
baseball no one cares uh but yeah no now
that uh it's a different it's kind of a
different environment a lot of uh a lot
of conservative voices are are back on
Twitter um I know a lot of people have
left for that threads thing or um not a
lot or whatever it is but some have it's
not a huge it seems like a it seems like
a place where people are um you know
able to say more right leaning things
now so yeah uh I was just seeing this on
CNN right now where they're covering Pro
Hamas protest can I see what this is I
just showed a kid how do you think this
ends when you're working on the amount
of precedent that there is um with
Israel with Gaza with the Palestinians
with Hamas I I don't foresee this ending
in a way that will feel very final
Israel has lost the innocent civilians
in Gaza have lost nobody can win a war
like this and so what does the end look
like it it looks like loss where do you
find the Hope in a situation like this I
have no hope that this conflict will be
resolved in The Next Century like not at
all I think this will be
an almost immutable fact of the Middle
East uh Israel Palestinian conflict this
is where I turn to religion and prayer
God and you know really the the core of
Judaism and that's so look let me let me
uh address this is one of I agree with
them the premise I agree with the
premise that this is not a conflict that
is going to end now sometimes you have
people say that and you can comment
comment below they'll say so this
conflict is not uh you know going to end
and it's nothing but loss
okay so if you believe that you're in a
conflict that will never end the goal is
to ensure that the enemy incurs the most
amount of losses possible while you
mitigate yours if it's never going to
end then why would you call for a
ceasefire if you acknowledge it's never
going it's like saying yeah I know this
is a tyrant I know it's a tyrant who's
who's going to take everything anyway so
let me give him some to start imagine if
Winston Churchill said you you cannot
negotiate with a tiger when your head is
in its mouth so just give him
everything you can say it's never going
to end therefore roll over or it's never
going to end so you accept the violence
wherever you line up on this conflict I
agree it's never going to end I think a
silly a silly uh thought process to
develop from that I think a silly
conclusion to which you come is
therefore let's try and have peace you
just said you can't give peace a chance
yeah so then don't they say it's never
going to end and they want a ceasefire
yeah if you have a ceasefire right now
and it's never going to end people are
just dying for nothing exactly people
all these people that were sad about I'm
sad about it of course it's not a great
thing I'm not happy about it but yeah
they all die in vain if if you just
cease fire you got to get rid of Hamas
as best you can then another another
group of initials will pop up under you
know a different Banner but which okay
since we do have Spencer coming up here
in a little bit we're going let's
address the Joe Biden emails uh tomorrow
just to be clear let me just give you a
quick recap K uh there was a lawsuit by
the southern Legal Foundation now they
just uncovered that Joe Biden sent
82,000 emails using pseudonyms during
his time as VP uh only Fox Business was
the one who broadcasted nothing in media
we're not going to show the clip but we
do know that there are some emails in
there from 2014 to 2019 uh when Hunter
served at bisma uh emails regarding that
we do know that there were emails in
2015 with uh vice presidential a John
Flynn um that included Hunter on these
emails that specifically addressed
Ukraine there were at least at least 10
emails at CCE Hunter Biden in relation
uh in many ways to Ukraine to barisma
and of course the Ukrainian uh uh
prosecutor uh Victor I believe Victor
shoken being dismissed these are these
are issues that are addressed in these
emails and the National Archive said
that they are going to be uh producing
more on a monthly basis so I don't want
to uh not do this topic Justice and I
think there's probably going to be more
tomorrow to cover so let me know if
you'd like us to cover that tomorrow uh
and if you have any information feel
free to send it in or comment below
because we're kind of still collecting
the data all right so to lead into what
a war in Gaza right now the ground
Invasion because you Josh is is here and
of course he has done how did you do
three tours two tours three tours to
Afghanistan wow thank thank you for
service oh I mean it was a it was pops
it I did I got it out can I have my pen
back okay you can some where is it I got
all I was too busy I was too busy an
a I don't
want whose dad didn't thank you for your
service because well Josh I my dad was a
career military fighter pilot retired
Colonel so I'm no one cares I've lived
under that Banner my whole life and I'm
quick to think it's like he said it's
like he says it's like oh I'm I'm a
quarter black so I can say the N word
thank him thank him for your service and
you move on so this is cramps Crowder
Yes this was something we were asking
what media Outlets do you trust in
relation to the Israel uh Palestine
Israel Hamas conflict really um I get it
I get it there's been misinformation on
both sides and that would be that would
be a tactic of war that would be pivotal
today I mean we just saw those tactics
of War being used by Twitter according
to Elon Musk why wouldn't a a government
military use it so let me ask you this
though you probably heard about um uh
jabalia the refugee camp there right
there was a strike okay so that's
probably what you've heard to begin with
now let me ask you this in your mind
right now take just a second if you're
on audio actually take a second in your
mind's eye I want you to picture what a
ref refugee camp looks like okay what do
you think of all right now we can bring
up do you think of something like this
right most likely mhm or do you think of
something like this this is the refugee
camp we are discussing in
jabalia no a city yes a city a city a
city like a yeah an apartment block yeah
bigger than the Chaz in Seattle yes it's
compare comparing uh comparing for
example a homeless tents in Austin in a
park to the Upper East Side
so let's contrast that to begin with
right you've heard about this refugee
camp uh or most like you can ask me I I
I'll ask you you can comment if you have
heard about the refugee camp in Gaza so
let's set this up yesterday the IDF
claimed responsibility which right away
should tip you off because they said the
hospital that was not us they said this
one guilty for striking the jabalia
refugee camp in Gaza but even if that
Hamas Commander was there amidst all
those Palestinian refugees who are in
that in that jabalia refugee camp he
looks like still went ahead and Dropped
a Bomb there attempting to kill this
Hamas this Kamas amamas Commander
knowing that a lot of innocent civilians
men women and children presumably would
be killed is that what I'm
hearing that's not what you're hearing
wol we again were focused on this
Commander again who you'll get more data
who this man was killed many many
Israelis uh we're doing everything we
can these are it's a very complicated
battle space there could be
infrastructure there there could be
tunnels there we're still looking into
it and we'll give you more data as the
moves ahead now just to be clear
everyone here is saddened when Innocent
Life Is Lost just to be clear and I do
get that not every single person in Gaza
or
Palestinian is supportive of Hamas or
wants to eradicate all the Jews as their
uh Representatives who were elected do
just to be clear but it also does matter
when you have one side using human
beings as human Shields again you think
of a refugee camp you don't think of a
major city with Shops and bodegas and
convenience stores and whatever their
equivalent written in that Arabic right
to Quick Trip is probably still quick
trip it's probably seven the Stop and
Rob yes stop and Rob stop and Rob hijab
now it's a franchise so uh the me the
media of grab and blow media Twitter
they were all flooded with videos
immediately claiming that the IDF
indiscriminately murdered some of them
claiming deliberately murdered innocent
women and children here's how they
painted it part of the jabalia refugee
camp among the largest and most densely
populated in Gaza now turned to Rubble
the latest Target of Israel's Relentless
air
campaign Israel dropped five bombs with
no warning the United Nations is saying
there is nowhere safe for Palestinians
right
now say Ministry of Health 400
Palestinians mostly women and children
there's nowhere safe it's almost almost
some Jews feel like there's nowhere safe
when you have a government saying our
goal is to eradicate all Jews M yeah
what's that security blanket yeah it's
like oh I just you know what I'll just
go on over here no no no that's still in
the eradication
Zone where is not in the ER no reate
means everywhere it's all mine there's
no what's mine is yours it's what's
yours is mine what's mine is mine
because you are Jew so Pi when your old
Rubble looks just like your new Rubble
it's kind of hard to
tell did you renovate in here oh Sim
Rubble this is this is uh I guess this
is modern uh rustic Chic that'll be
that'll be rebuilt by next week it's
contemporary Arab world since forever so
I get we're talking about Israel okay
and Palestine the whole thing it's not a
real country all right so Pierce Morgan
also forcefully uh condemned this action
writing Israel deliberately bombing
gaza's largest refugee camp even if a
Hamas Commander was there is outrageous
and
indefensible okay so what do we know
about this refugee camp all right well
here's a couple of fast facts for you
number
one this was a refugee camp established
in uh 1948 uh was established after
Egypt conquered Gaza during the
1948 area Israeli War I said Gaza cuz I
was still in Pierce Morgan mind Gaza
Gaza Hamas Gaza I still have a little
bit of Macho Man Randy Savage from
yesterday was all night they in Gaza
yeah tell you that gets that gets the
Macho Man a little bit irritated no I
don't want to beab Israeli War prisoner
no cuz the cream Rises to the top that's
the
IDF when the IDF comes knocking on your
door you're going to know who the real
Mach man is it was all night my pops was
there I was doing it look just just to
add some levity here with my kids and uh
we were trick-or-treating and I put it
on and I was doing and they loved it
then at one point I take off my glasses
and I go hey it's dadada and my son goes
no D is no fun at all goes be macho man
all right I guess I'm not going to have
a voice tomorrow going to be horse yeah
you were like getting in the character
yesterday if I took it out if I took
anything off like no no no Macho Man all
right one of the dads on one of the
porches says you keep that up you'll
talk to nobody
tomorrow that was a guy who was drinking
an IPA in a sports yeah cuz he likes
beer that tastes like soap yeah Mao man
doesn't like beer that tastes like soap
no figuratively speaking all
right so this is watch men being
articulate figuratively
speaking so the jabali refugee camp okay
established 1948 after the Arab uh
Israeli War okay these aren't refugees
the context here what I'm trying to tell
you is fleeing Israeli air strikes okay
it's located just 2 to 3 miles uh from
gaza's North border is that the area
where the Israelis told everybody to
evacuate like two or three weeks ago
right and so Israel sent some warnings
to the South they have been sending
warnings no warnings no warning it needs
to well you need a warning then you need
you need you need to do continual
warnings because that's what people do
in war yeah okay yeah you need to be we
were doing it wrong yeah now you need to
have your own Paul Riv on retainer for
the other guy and nowadays the rules are
coming the Jews are
coming that would be best if your power
be's Macho Man listen I got to tell you
something okay yeah the Jews are coming
they're bringing Hellfire with them with
the Macho Man yeah the Jews are coming
here and they're wearing Fringe and
they're wearing Fringe and at the end of
the day doesn't matter what you do with
the idea of no you're just going to be a
Palestinian kid throwing rocks in an
Israeli tank
yeah
was all night it was four
Ops it never got old there was new
material in every house keep it up
there's not going to be a Thursday
show I had a kid sneeze he he was so
fasc with the maun he walked up sneezed
in my face like it was a bioweapon and
then wiped it on my Macho suit what I
don't know I don't know if he had a cold
I mean you can't do anything about it
there's no observancy in that suit Nock
all right that kid was working with the
iron Chic yes he was well do you
remember when the Macho Man went up to
the kid in the vampire suit and
complimented him on his on his outfit oh
the Dracula suit yeah the Dracula yeah
that's right he was anyway it's a whole
thing he's just trying to queue me up
for more Macho he was the one he like
hey do you want Macho Man like do you
want Macho Man to whatever it is you
know steep in a bucket of snakes like
yeah well I guess because Macho Man's
pops wants me to step in a bucket of
snakes I don't want to disappoint the
kids
no all night all right here's another
key fact okay uh the camp the refugee
camp is completely indistinguishable
from the rest of the city here's an
aerial picture showing how the refugee
camp showing you exactly how it Blends
in with the rest even the media they
can't agree on what the borders of the
camp actually are wherever the bombs
fell
yes it's pretty easy to me and the it's
an urban environment again you would
think refugee camp you think T no it's
incredibly densely populated it's
82,000 82,000 give or take people per
square kilometer to give you context New
York City is about 10,000 people per
square kilm oh dang so you need to keep
this in context where okay if terrorists
are setting up tunnels and
Rockets and they're doing it in an area
where there are as many women and
children as possible again this is war
do do you allow them to kill your women
and children or do you go after the
terrorists and I'm sorry but collateral
damage unfortunately results with women
and children because they're firing
their Rockets deliberately using women
and children as human Shields look at
those Maps that's where they picked
that's where they picked to set this up
and the media just read away this is
completely indefensible I disagree I
don't think it's completely indefensible
when you understand context here's
another key fact uh this has been a
Target this refugee camp for the IDF
since the very start of the war the IDF
has claimed that Hamas their leadership
have used uh jabala to shelter
themselves to hide now they could be
biased here from the IDF that's why I
ask you what sources do you think are
reliable now I tend to I tend to when
Hamas IDF or government of Israel I tend
to give more weight to the government of
Israel but I I do certainly do not think
that they are unbiased but it's because
Hamas you know they brag about murdering
innocent women and
children so it's not that much of a
stretch when the IDF says by the way
they're murdering their own women and
children we do know also according to Al
jazer that this refugee camp was used
for Hamas activities regularly here's Al
jaer in 2014 it says gaza's internal
tunnel network is reportedly even more
complex than crossb routes and involves
multiple branches that run under refugee
camps uh in conun jabalia other densely
populated areas they hide weaponry and
they are designed for Hamas leadership
to remain protected and mobile this is
from Al jazer in 2014 which means this
has been going on since at least then
where it was not up for debate because
you know Al jazer really wants to paint
them in a more positive light here's a
Hamas terrorist giving uh a Russia Today
journalist and by the way just so you
know I'm glad that Rumble allows Russia
Today to be on their platform because I
want to hear what Hamas terrorists have
to say that's the beauty of freedom of
speech that's the beauty of being
representative of all of humanity warts
and all here's a Hamas terrorist giving
a Russia Today journalist a guided tour
of those
tunnels
okay so here's the thing if you think
it's indefensible that any type of
strike results in the death of of of of
women and children that is a position to
hold I understand that there are people
who believe that there should be no war
ever whatsoever however what is not a
defensible position is the idea that
this was simply a refugee camp that was
targeted with the intent of killing
women and children how do we know from
hamas's own rep representatives from Al
jazer from every source that we have
available that lets us know that
terrorists were there I get now could
there be a middle ground could the IDF
have said nah you know what there's
probably another way to extract this
person but who cares at this point we're
past hitting the fit button
maybe but that's a danger of going out
half coocked with very little of the
information and not providing historical
context all the references we will make
available for you at ladder with cr.com
link in the description comment but you
ask at the outset what is your picture
in your mind my mind immediately goes to
these people using women and children
all the time I I never accept their
explanation because and it's not a
matter of opinion it's not bias they've
proven themselves so yeah I I don't I
don't understand why people still
believe that they're lucky they didn't
get a MOAB with tunnels that strong I
don't know if people believe it I I
think we've reached you know there used
to be the argument used to be people
believed uh that they weren't using
women and children as human shields uh
and what I see from the left now they're
not not denying it but they're saying
ceasefire anyway you want to believe
that that's not true it's like no I
think they're accepting the premise I
going Sur they use Women and Children of
Shields and sure they do do that and
they're terrorists but you know what
ceasefire anyway I saw someone arguing
the other day about that they were
saying if a if if somebody kidnapped
your uh kidnapped your mom and had a gun
to their head and you were a cop would
you still shoot and kill your mom and I
was like that's a terrible like they're
just accepting that they're using human
Shields and they they still shouldn't
yeah well they use when they say things
like we value death more than you value
life I mean come on folks well actually
okay a modern society on the other side
of the line it's a completely different
culture we have our guest who is going
to be here in a little bit so before
that we want to set this up regarding uh
you know the land Invasion that has
started in Gaza and what I mean by that
is there was you know air there were air
strikes going on the war in the Middle
East is obviously intensifying quite a
bit and so uh we were thinking who would
be better to run us through it than
before our guest of course Mr Spencer uh
we have our own resident Ranger here
which brings us to a new segment we call
Josh knows
[Music]
War thank you for your
service we spared no expense so and
you'll probably be better to interview
our Our Guest uh uh Mr Spencer on here I
have all of his credentials uh in a
couple of minutes but first let me just
rattle this off so people kind of
understand the context you know what a
ground war looks like having done three
tours yeah and this is only really
started the ground Invasion with Gaza as
opposed to air strikes uh four days ago
I believe we have a clip Israel's
military forces expanded its ground
activities in Gaza As It prepares for a
full-scale ground Invasion Fireballs lit
up Northern gaza's blacked out
Skyline their blasts rolling past
seconds
later Israel Defense Forces said fighter
jets struck 150 targets underground
including hamas's Maze of hundreds of
miles of tunnels while Columns of
Israeli tanks rolled into the strip all
right so you guys have probably been
following this you know uh that uh this
has been going on for about four days
and of course not everyone has supported
uh the ground Invasion and that's an
opinion that people of course can hold
that's valid for examu uh for for
example for example Emanuel macron
macron not a fan
he said a ground Invasion it is aimed at
terrorist groups that are totally
identified it is their choice that
matches the description I just gave if
it is a massive ground Invasion which
puts civilian lives at risk then I think
that it is a mistake and it is a mistake
for Israel as well let's just think of
how stupid those two paragraphs are if
it's aimed at terrorist groups that are
totally identified it is their choice if
it is a massive ground Invasion which
puts civilian lives at risk did you spot
the stupid what if it's aimed at
terrorists were easily identified behind
the women and children human shield mhm
what would Napoleon do he would
people up yes what he would do also I
like the wouldn't stand for this
for one moment he would not but I am
what you call how you say I am a
boy
yes I
am because it doesn't protect Israel in
the long term and because it is
incompatible with respect of civilians
of the humanitarian national law and the
law of War I believe this would be a
mistake we actually go now live to
macron's cabinet for
[Applause]
commentary you hear that
laugh that was exactly how he
laugh that's not how he
laughed kill the dog yes are you pissing
on the fireplace did you say you are
with Hamas the our guess yeah are
guess try as a hummus it's
delicious don't believe me ask the
dishes right the dishes are juice I'm
sorry the CL trying to eradicate my
dishes the clock is just a former Nazi
all right and the UN he had little
mustache like that
must silence
Hitler you were supposed to have died in
Argentine was as a
SS all right that's a deep PLL now the
UN Secretary General uh Antonio gutterz
also called for a ceasefire to his epic
suffering make the deliver of a easier
and safer and facilitate the release of
hostages I reiterate my appeal for an
immediate humanitarian
ceasefire no no look here's the thing
wherever you line
up you don't get to call for a ceasefire
after the deliberate targeting of women
and children to a record number you
don't get to then call you don't get to
rape somebody you don't get to March
into someone's house shoot their family
members and then when the cops come call
for a ceasefire that is akin to
supporting
terrorism
[Music]
oh
we're just missing
rafik I'm sure we can fit illon Omar in
there so despite pressure from the
internet here just let's just hear the
let's hear okay so you hear their side
now let's hear the the Jewish side
here's Israel Prim Minister Benjamin n
saying uh uh go fornicate yourself
Israel will not agree to a sociation of
hostilities with Hamas after the
horrific attacks of October
7th calls for a ceasefire are calls for
Israel to surrender to Hamas to
surrender to terrorism to surrender to
barbarism the Bible says that there is a
Time For Peace and a time for war this
is a time for
war but when ibody hear barbarism for
some reason I still think of like just
like a Barbers
Union we will not stand for haircuts in
this country will not stand for a
haircut is it wrong that I want him to
narrate every audio book ever ever again
Netanyahu what a voice he does have a
pretty damn good voice you know he
sounds like Dr gu groma a little bit
when we were kids only with a Jewish ACC
yeah with a Jewish so here and this is
sorry because I wanted to go through
this because our guest is waiting but I
really do want to get your perspective
here uh to get a better idea of how a
ground Invasion might actually unfold
what the IDF soldiers can expect um we
have our resident Ranger here Josh firin
thank you for your service and then we
also have as a guest a guest retired US
Army Officer I want to make sure I get
all these right he's a current uh
colonel in the uh California state guard
he is a chair of urban Warfare studies
at the Modern War Institute at West
Point and author of understanding Urban
Warfare I think I've covered it all Mr
John
[Music]
Spencer all right John Spencer can you
hear me see me sir thank you for being
here I can see you and hear you thanks
for having me all right well thank you I
apologize for the uh The Lion King in
ruction but we're okay with it now um
here uh before cuz I really would like
for you to speak with Josh you know Josh
here has done three tours um of Duty
himself and by the way thank you both
for your service uh could you give uh
the viewing uh audience the person right
now watching listening a bit of your
background um kind of what it is that
you do sure so I spent 25 years in the
Army as an infantry Soldier both as a
soldier and an officer two combat
deployments to Iraq one in the invasion
and then one in 2008 during the height
of basically searan violence in Baghdad
and then I went into basically academics
after my career where I've been studying
all Urban Warfare from the Ancient
Warfare to today uh for over a decade
and writing have a podcast and walking
the ground I go in and out of Ukraine I
go narak I've been to Israel I've been
to many of these places that were
viciously slaughtered uh I've eaten
lunch in sardot and a lot of that so I'm
a student of all of this and hopefully
can help people understand what they're
seeing like you were talking about yeah
not try to go crazy about it well it's
hard to to sort of parse you know uh
reality from from fiction right now and
I understand why people don't trust
either side as far as the media Josh
what would be kind of if someone who's
been on the ground what would be your
your main question as far as um I guess
what are the unknowns here well for me I
was all my tours were Afghanistan and
they were all after 2000 or 2009 or
later so it's a lot different than what
you did Colonel and going into Iraq and
and going through the invasion um I
think we're kind of looking at a similar
thing at least from the outside it
appears to be a similar situation and
I'm kind of thinking like what what
would be Israel's ultimate goal in this
Crown Invasion going into
Gaza yeah I mean that's a great question
I think it's actually pretty clear
despite some of the comments from the
political leaders from a military guys
an analyst of these type of operations
is very clear destroy Hamas military
capability so they can never do another
October 7th 9911 event or send another
rocket towards Israel civilians you have
to move forward you have to destroy
people Rockets tunnels everything it's
it's actually a very clear-cut military
objective as opposed to some of the
other ones that I've seen like which
which ones would you say are not
necessarily clear-cut uh when the day
after right when you have to stay around
and build a nation and and try to
instill democracy and things like that
are foreign to that environment right
militaries can destroy other military
capabilities militaries are horrible at
building Nations that makes sense you
think there's no interest for Israel to
rebuild anything after coming through
and or or setting up a new government if
they eradicate eradicate yeah if they
well Hamas I'm Pro eradicating Hamas
yeah if they destroy Hamas and their
Hamas government in
Gaza well yes so the day day after right
so that's always the question for any
military any military operation Israel
says they have no intentions of
governing God ever again but yeah I mean
Hamas is not the only terrorist
organization even in Gaza right you have
pji lionen it's it's full of terrorists
uh so who governs it and then again
doesn't become a threat again to Israel
will be determined their approach but
right now it's there's no other
alternative that's kind of the issue
here too is that everybody wants to talk
about the ceasefire all this like there
is no other alternative here's an
alternative every Hamas member
surrenders and there's a complete
disarmament of Hamas military capability
in Gaza which is literally you can see
it from Israel it's not it's not like
it's some people have this idea again
like you said about the refugee camp
which is just a classification in which
you can get more aid from the United
Nation uh you have an idea of a refugee
camps not a like a a concrete City you
have an idea that Gaza is some Far Away
place from Israel it's it's literally in
eyesight and the rockets come and have
come every day since October 7th out of
Gaza heading towards an isra Israeli
civilian site yeah it'd be like being in
Manhattan and having having Rockets
being failed from Hoboken um yes let me
uh ask you just as a Layman when you say
this because it seems like there can be
no the idea of ceasefire just seems so
silly considering what happened right in
uh uh in O now we're in November so back
in October gosh times moves almost a
month now yeah but what why was there
such a delay as far as going into you
know graa Gaza graa going into you know
I graze it's just it's a meal going into
Gaza by by land um why was there a delay
will that hinder or will it help
Israel's chances of success and
obviously there's a difference between
the air strikes and the missiles but
boots on the ground why the
delay I mean it takes so the there's
many number one it takes a long time to
to to gather an army of this size
especially the the way that Israel
relies on their reserved Force right the
bankers and everybody stops what they're
doing and goes back to their units and
forms up and gets all the tanks and all
the bulldozers and everything in
position um it isn't like they just
planned this in the last two weeks
either that they've had plans for
decades for the possibility of this
operation and then like you said Israel
started asking for evacuations you can't
demand evacuations on October 7th right
especially in the Hamas strongholds
which is if you look at like you said
jabala is in that Northeastern sector of
Gaza where IDF said from day one this is
where the majority of the combat is
please evacuate from these areas yeah
and 800,000 supposedly have but that's
another reason why you like the right
thing to do not even the legal
requirement right like the US doesn't
call a building before we strike it in
any wars that I've ever been in um in
that ability to attack a city the right
thing to do is provide time for all
non-combatants although Hamas doesn't
wear a uniform to get out of the Cities
so that's a reason but you it's also
about putting in all the US capabilities
you know Israel this is not new to
Israel having to go to war after being
attacked right it was attacked by five
nations during The Six Day War and then
young K po War but it's always had to
stand alone and I and as a a US citizen
I was really proud of when the US said
Israel's had to stand alone before but
they'll never have to stand alone again
right so getting those us ships as
people think like the the the carrier
strike groups into the area to be able
to stop somebody like Iran or Syria or
some from getting involved that takes
time well an important distinction
because look I have said not one
American solders Life loss for the war
between Israel and and Hamas um is my
point of view but I think that morally
they need to be supported in defending
themselves that's very different however
from hey look let them H let them duke
it out Oran we've got our eye on you
right flicking that that's different
because Iran is a threat to American
National Security would you would you
agree with that assessment that that is
a reasonable view for people to have we
do not get involved ourselves directly
with Israel Hamas but certainly uh we
have to have our eye on Iran and you
know Place Hezbollah when we're talking
about Lebanon we're talking about Yemen
a lot of people who could jump in that's
right and and defensively that that also
means that we can knock Rockets out of
the sky they're heading to to Israel
civilian
sites right and uh what do you have um
did you have another question there Josh
because again I don't know because
you've been in the actual you know I'm
just we're all here we're I'm you
boy what the a boy yeah well I
didn't want to go into you know I never
wanted join the military largely because
you know NE small hands uh but you know
the Canadian military a little bit
different I didn't want to be you know I
didn't want to be an assessa 182 with a
shotgun that's why I didn't want to join
the Air Force you know so if I was in
the states I might have been a little
Bolder Canadians the Nazis of
Kandahar but uh but yeah what would what
is so these soldiers these these IDF
soldiers going into Gaza what would what
does it look like for them uh what what
kind of obstacles will they face and how
quickly do you think they can uh
accomplish their objectives going in to
an urban Warfare uh and if I could add
to that I think for a Layman right
because a lot of people will say hey you
know what when people talk about the
Second Amendment the Taliban right these
guys out there who are just basically
using monkey bars and old AKs they were
able to hold off in many ways the
strongest military that's ever existed
right the American Military a big part
of that was just home court advantage
how big of a role does that play here
because the home the home advantages
these urban areas that are used in
people as human
Shields yeah I mean I think there's a
there's a kind of a bills curve of scum
on the earth and some use human Shields
some don't Hamas uses and builds all of
it infrastructure for the sole purpose
of restricting what IDF soldiers can do
um in accordance with the law of War
because that a professional military
with values ethics follows the law of
war in in despite the two-sided
conversation so what does this look for
the IDF is that you of course Hamas has
prepared for decades for this likelihood
right so they but very asymmetrically
not they're not dumb like the Iraqi
military who tried to stand toe-to-toe
with the US military they're going to
try to fight asymmetrically like hide in
holes hide in tunnels um pop up from
hard buildings and use snipers and use
IEDs that that are very familiar to US
soldiers um and try to trip the IDE of
forces or pull them into the urban area
where there's a lot of advantages from
being able to pick which whole which
window you shoot from and and surprise
the IDF that has to move forward and
then the IDF side that it looks like a
very slow um deliberate clearing
operation but the idea uniquely are
again our designed for this right the
idea isn't like the US military that has
to be prepared to fight globally against
our enemies they they're fighting home
literally like they can see their house
from where they're fighting right and
they prepared they have unque bulldozers
that we don't have that are two stories
tall that can be remote controlled that
will go forward into the urban area take
the shot from the terrorist and then
okay now I know where you are I can drop
the building if I want or or engage it
in with the tank round of a movement to
contact type of thing it is it is it
really is um and this is why it's Unique
too this is something that the IDF
hasn't really done in in a very long
time even the past operations into Gaza
I mean they used to occupy guys right
they used to 2005 they left that's right
and then 2008 they went back in
operation castled 2014 they went back
but they were very limited operations
yeah like they didn't try to punch to
the middle of Gaza City this will be
hell I mean look up uh I mean 10 20
story buildings where the enemy could be
launching anything down on top of you um
this is the the ideal and I know you
were talking about before is the ideal
that this is a this can be some type of
surgical operation like no in the
history of urban Warfare it will look
like it was carpon bombed even when it
wasn't it'll look like raised Earth it
will look like hell on Earth is is there
any or to what extent I guess uh could
civilian casualties I guess be avoided
the way you're describing it is it a
loss cause or are there things that that
can be done can I add to that question
yeah yeah yeah please do uh also yeah to
add to that question do you think it be
it's going to be less casualties or less
uh destructive than bombing
right so actually this is the Paradox
where I tell people if you want to cause
less destruction in urban areas you need
a bulldozer in a tank because if not if
you don't have those if you don't go
into urban are you try to bomb it one
there's there's never been in history
that that achieves this level of Miss
Mission you don't you can't even
convince the enemy to give up by just
straight bombing uh and Hamas terrorist
is willing to die and actually sacrifice
all their Palestinian civilians in Gaza
for their cause which is the destruction
of Israel and all Jewish people how do
you so is it a lost cause no again there
are legal requirements that must be
taken by the IDF like asking civilians
to leave like identifying only military
targets you can't shoot at a hospital a
mosque anything like that unless it's
being used for military purposes so this
is the thing that people want to over
you kind of gloss over in the media is
that the IDF have done Beyond
requirements to get civilians out of the
way right and that's why amazingly in
jabal after that strike there's hundreds
of military ageed Mills standing around
the crater like what are you doing there
like that that that is just where you've
been asked to leave for your own safety
for the safety of your families if
they're still there right so IDF
actually does other things that we don't
do again calling buildings before they
strike them like calling everybody and
sending everybody in the building of Tex
to include the enemy we're about to hit
this building you have an hour to get
out uh they'll they'll there's all kinds
of things the idef do to limit coll
civilian casualties so they have pretty
extensive Rules of Engagement then they
do too yeah positive positive positive
identification of the enemy I mean it
kind but this is the thing there's been
in the 2017 Battle of mul and again it
was against Isis so I guess the media
didn't care as much there was 10,000
civilian casualties in the Battle of mul
which was Iraqi Security Forces backed
by US military air power yeah well I
want continue this but we're going a
little bit over time here can uh I'd
like to continue on on on mug Club here
in a moment for those because we can
take their chat as well where's the best
play uh place for people to find you
John Spencer I know your your book
understanding Urban Warfare is available
everywhere is there anywhere else people
can go in yeah John Spencer online.com I
I'm trying to throw all my stuff onto
that website okay John Spencer
online.com this is fascinating for me
and I want uh I want to hear more
between you know you and Josh by the way
thank you all for your service we
appreciate it and if you are watching
right now and we do have an open
invitation to any Hamas representative
Pro Palestinian Hamas representative on
this show to present their side of the
issues it's not going to be a Pierce
Morgan situation uh where we would like
to uh keep people accountable and
members of the IDF I'd love to have a
split screen with all of you this
conversation is important of course you
know where I line up I don't lie about
my biases if you're on Rumble click this
button join mug Club because none of
this happens without you uh we're going
to continue with John Spencer thank you
Rumble YouTube piss
off
[Applause]
what